let's consider a reaction with the
following multi-step mechanism
in step 1 a reacts with bc to form
ac plus b and in step 2
ac reacts with d to form a plus
d if we add the two steps of our
mechanism together we can find the
balanced equation for this hypothetical
reaction so we're going to put all of
our reactants
on the left side here and we're going to
have all of our products on the right
side
and we can see that ac is on the left
and it's on the right side so we can
cancel that out
a is also on the left and the right side
so we can cancel
that out so the overall equation would
be
c plus d
goes to b
plus c d
we've just seen that b c and d are our
reactants
and b and c d are the
products for this hypothetical reaction
if we look at the mechanism a is there
in the beginning
and a is there in the end but a is not a
reactant or a product
therefore a must be a catalyst
something else that's not a reactant or
product is ac
notice how ac was generated in the first
step of our mechanism and then
ac is used up in the second step of the
mechanism
therefore ac must be the
intermediate for this reaction
next let's look at the energy profile
for this multi-step reaction
energy profiles usually have potential
energy on the y-axis and then reaction
progress
on the x-axis so as we move to the right
on the x-axis the reaction is occurring
this first line on our energy profile
represents the energy level of our
reactants which are b
c and d so let's go ahead and show the
bond
between b and c
and then we also have d present
our catalyst is also present at the very
beginning of our reaction so i'll
go ahead and draw in a above our two
reactants
we can see in our energy profile that we
have two
hills the first hill corresponds to the
first step of the mechanism and the
second hill corresponds to the second
step so the peak of the first hill
is the transition state for the first
step
of the mechanism and we can see in the
first step
that the catalyst a is colliding with bc
or reacting with bc to form our
intermediate
ac so a must collide
with bc and at the transition state
the bond between b and c is breaking
and at the same time the bond between a
and c
is forming
we would still have reactant d present
at the top of this hill too so i'll go
ahead and draw in
d here when a collides with
bc the collision has to have
enough kinetic energy to overcome
the activation energy necessary for this
reaction to occur
and on this energy profile the
activation energy
is the difference in energy between the
reactants and the
transition state so the very peak of the
hill so this
difference in energy corresponds to the
activation energy for the first step
of the mechanism which we will call ea1
if we assume that the collision has
enough kinetic energy to overcome the
activation energy
we'll form our intermediate ac and we'd
also form
b so let's go ahead and show the bond
between
a and c has now been formed so this
valley here between our two hills
represents the energy level
of the intermediate we would also have b
present so i can go ahead and i'll just
write in b
here and then we still have some d
present d still hasn't reacted yet
so i'll go ahead and draw in d as well
next we're ready for the second hill or
the second step of our mechanism
in the second step ac the intermediate
ac
reacts with d to form a and
c d so the top of the second hill would
be the transition state for
this second step so we can show the bond
between
a and c breaking at the same time the
bond between
c and d is forming
the difference in energy between the
energy of the intermediate and the
energy of the transition state
represents the activation energy for the
second step
of the mechanism which we will call
e a 2 so
a c and d must collide with enough
kinetic energy to
overcome the activation energy for this
second step
if ac and d collide with enough kinetic
energy
we would produce a and cd
so this line at the end here represents
the energy level
of our products so
cd is one of our products so we'll write
that
in here and remember b
is our other product which we formed
from the
first step of the mechanism so let's go
ahead and write
in here b plus c d
and we also reformed our catalyst so a
would be present here as well next let's
compare
the first activation energy ea1 with the
second activation energy ea2
looking at the energy profile we can see
that ea1
is a much greater activation energy than
ea2 so let's go ahead and write ea1
is greater than ea2 the smaller the
activation energy the faster the
reaction
and since there's a smaller activation
energy for the second step the second
step must be
the faster of the two since the first
step has the higher activation energy
the first step must be slow compared
to the second step
since the first step of the mechanism is
the slow step the first step
is the rate determining step
finally let's find the overall change in
energy for
our reaction so to find the overall
change in energy that's
delta e which is final minus initial
so that would be the energy of the
products minus
the energy of the reactants so the
energy
level of the products is right here and
then the energy level the reactants is
at the beginning so let me just extend
this dashed line here so we can better
compare the two representing delta e on
a graph it would be the difference
in energy between these two lines
and since the energy of the products is
greater than the energy of the reactants
we would be subtracting a smaller number
from a larger number and therefore
delta e would be positive for this
hypothetical reaction
and since delta e is positive we know
that this reaction
is an endothermic reaction